yeah the book did make me feel really
good about being human on that level
where it made us seem like these swiss
army knives where we show up
and then we
niche switch uh we specialize we have
this like combination of generalists and
specialists who then manage to overrun
any habitat
it's good news with a giant asterisk on
it right the fact is
we are an incredibly special species and
we are adapted to something that no
other species i mean species deal with
it but we are adapted to change it's
what we do we bootstrap new software to
deal with new problems right we're very
good at it and that does offer nothing
but hope for the pickle we're in because
if any species was going to work you
know we created this problem but we're
also positioned really well to figure
out how to get out of it but
it comes with a lot of other stuff
selection has been pushing us in the
direction of just simply
getting our lineages genes into the
future at any cost and so the point is
human beings are capable of all kinds of
terrible stuff too
and
you know the deepest message in the book
may be
that it is time for us to take evolution
the mindless process out of the driver's
seat and to recognize our evolutionary
purpose isn't interesting or honorable
but we are perfectly capable of defining
a purpose that is worthy of us and
that's exactly what we should do at this
moment in history yeah that was the
conclusion of the book which was really
profound in talking about the fourth
frontier which is something that a lot
of people i think would agree with that
where
collision course with disaster species
wide
that this growth imperative
will
eventually make no sense uh it did put
me in mind of
jared diamond's book collapsed from a
while ago which i'm sure you both
uh read read when it came out
it's consistent with what a lot of
people think in terms of the
sustainability of the environment where
if you have
companies that have a growth imperative
that eventually and societies you point
out that our population is now at seven
billion which by the way when when we
were all growing up what was the world's
population well it depends how early you
go but um i recall i recall it crossing
into
above seven in our adult lifespans well
because i i ask because i remember as a
kid when i learned how many people were
on earth i think it was either two or
three billion and so as a person that
number stuck in my head
and then when someone told me it was
seven billion later i was like when it
becomes seven billion so i i want
someone to take a look at like what you
know whether or not i'm misremembering
you
guys
i don't think you are i remember
thinking about this about my
grandfather's lifespan my grandfather
was born in 1913
and the world population doubled twice
while he was on earth which is a
staggering fact yeah right and you know
we point out in the book that our desire
for growth is not unusual and you know
that's just like the goal being to
reproduce yourself into the future as
far as possible is not unusual it's also
not honorable so you know how do we
harness that desire you understand the
desire both for a personal sense of
growth and sort of a societal sense of
growth and abundance and there's always
more around the next corner and turn it
into something that is has the sense of
growth without actually requiring the
use of more resources because we can't
keep doing that yeah so we're going to
come back to what we're going to do
species wide but i want to explore some
of the key ideas in the book and there's
so many
you talk about medicine food sleep
parenthood
relationships so you could do a podcast
about really any one of these
but i was trying to distill some of the
key points
and one of the things that stuck with me
is a story about
brett breaking his wrist and then having
uh like what sounds like a nightmarish
couple days like where it's like
excruciating pain and
that you end up taking another trip with
it
and
[Music]
uh talk about how after a lot of
hardship
um eventually it healed and healed well
but that 95 of people would have
immobilized it cast it
maybe taken some pharmaceutical
painkillers
have done a bunch of other things
that
address one aspect of the injury either
the bone or the pain
but don't necessarily address the entire
thing in terms of soft tissue recovery
or
usability or any of those things and i
thought that that story
one
you know it sticks with you because you
know no one wants to be going for days
with a broken wrist without drugs in my
opinion i mean
i mean
like i'd like to think that i'd do the
same thing you did but who the heck
knows um but but there was something um
where that principle applied many times
throughout the book where that you're
trying to hone in on one particular bad
thing you're getting rid of um and then
in the process of getting rid of that
bad thing
uh you end up having unintended uh
effects elsewhere yeah now that's
exactly right and with regard to that
particular story there's at least two
there's at least two things at play
we've got the fact that human bodies and
brains are actually anti-fragile right
we actually become stronger with use
with with insult even you know to a
point there you know there are certainly
insults and injuries beyond which we
cannot recover beyond which we cannot
repair
but the response to immobilize
all kinds of injuries which actually
would withstand would not only withstand
but actually repair more quickly if they
were able to continue to be used
is an aspect of modern medicine that you
know we argue is is an error because
because it's employed as a hard and fast
rule you know when you break something
you immobilize it as opposed to what
kind of break is it does this one
warrant that kind of immobilization and
if so for how long etc and then there's
also just the tendency to reduce
um
our experiences to single parts of
single parts of what they are i'm
feeling pain pain doesn't feel good
therefore i must get rid of it instead
of recognizing that pain is an adaptive
response uh which we should consider you
know what is it that the pain is telling
me what might it be that i am doing that
i can reduce such the pain goes away so
that i can use the pain as an indicator
of whether or not my behavior is helping
me or harming me as opposed to get rid
of the pain so that i can continue on
with frankly whatever i might be doing
that's causing me to be in pain so i
would uh i would just add
the
incident i broke my wrist i fell off a a
hoverboard that um our younger sister
those things are death traps by the way
not kidding those things are not i i i'm
a big fan of the electric unicycle but i
i would agree with you the hoverboard is
a death trap
both in terms of its battery and also
its control mechanism but anyway i fell
off one as i was getting on it for the
first time
and i felt my wrist crack i knew what
had happened
and
the thing is i had harbored the
following belief for
i don't know since i first learned about
biology in high school
which is we are a kind of creature that
has limbs that can repair from a break
because many of our ancestors had brakes
recovered had offspring after that right
not every creature is like that a horse
is famously difficult to repair a broken
limb because a horse's ancestors if they
broke a limb very quickly got eaten by
predators and so there's no selective
force to build the repair machinery so
my feeling was okay i'm a creature that
knows how to repair its own limbs why is
the instinct to go to a doctor who then
immobilizes and does something that
is a novel intervention
surely nature has a program for what to
do now one caveat
i made very sure
that what i had was a fracture in which
nothing was misaligned there was no
indication that i had broken all the way
through right it was a crack
and i learned my lesson right i started
immediately
utilizing it just a little right that
was the thing that got me in so much
pain that first night
uh was that i used it too much i was not
super cautious with it right away but it
wasn't even weeks before i was way
better off right it was a few days
before i had some use of my limb and
then it quickly got better and you know
it very much reflected my hypothesis
that there's a built-in program and it
probably beats the heck out of a cast if
your break is sufficiently minor
and we do we do also as you know tell
the story in the book of our oldest son
breaking his arm when he was very young
and it was such a remarkable break um
that he needed surgical intervention and
you know without without modern surgical
capacity he would be deformed now you
know his arm would have stopped growing
uh and you know he would have you know
he would be very asymmetric and have
much lower functionality absent that
capacity so this again you know there
are no set and forget rubrics here and
that you know that also is one of the
messages of evolutionary thinking is
that it actually is clarifying and
simplifying but you do have to carry
around with you an expectation that
whatever happens okay i'm gonna have to
think this through just a little bit
from first principles to see what i
should do next as opposed to it's a
break cast it you know that's too simple
a rubric yeah and in fact uh in our
older son zack's case when he broke his
arm it also points to the central theme
in our book which is about novelty and
what it can do to you in fact our point
is that we are in a stage of hyper
novelty right novelty humans deal with
well hyper novelty no creature deals
with
and our older son when he broke his arm
in the spectacular way it was a
combination of a couple of mundane novel
factors a small set of stairs and a
hippity hop neither of which have any
analogy in the ancestral environment and
the combination of them resulted in a
child doing something that would have
been a rarity for an ancestor right the
forces were just too great and the break
was beyond what a normal repair would
handle
[Music]
you